there was a great BBC series um where
they focus on the secret life of plants
just by speeding up things 10 or 100
times and they look very sentient you
when you do that yeah speak our
ancestors said that one day in Fairyland
a seven years in human land maybe this
alludes to this temporal
difference so about differences between
you all why don't we Linger on
Consciousness and Carl if you don't mind
answering what is consciousness where is
consciousness and why is consciousness
so in other words where is it is it in
the brain is it in the entire body is it
an IL defined question what is it why do
we have it what is its function and then
we'll see where this Compares and
contrast with yosi's thinking right um
yeah I I am not a philosopher um and
sometimes the story I will tell depends
on who I am talking to um but and its
simplest um I find it easiest to think
of Consciousness as a process as opposed
to a thing or a state um and
specifically a process of computation if
you like or belief updating um so I
normally start thinking about questions
um of the kind you just asked me but
replacing Consciousness with Evolution
so where is
evolution um you know what is evolution
why is evolution then all of those
questions I think quite easy to answer
sometimes it's a stupid question uh
sometimes um there's a very clear answer
um so you know where where is
consciousness where is evolution well it
is in the substrate that um is evolving
um so you know where is consciousness it
will be in this the processes um that
you are are ascribing Consciousness so I
would say it it is actually the
computation or the information
processing the belief abating that you
get at any level uh and just you know
fully um um acknowledging Josh's point
that it doesn't have to be neurons it
could be um my sealed networks it could
be um intercellular communication it
could be um it could be electrical
filaments you know as long there is a
physical instantiation of a process that
can be read as a kind of um belief
updating or processing um if I were
allowed to
um um computation you know as as that
kind of process then that would have um
that would be I think what Consciousness
where Consciousness would be found um
would that be sufficient to ascribe uh
Consciousness to me or to something else
I suspect not I think you'd have to go a
little bit further and um um suspect
that Jos would wants to now articulate
how much further but there will be a
focus on self-modeling um so it's not
just a process of inference it's
actually inference under um a kind of
model of the world and I would you know
I'm quite happy committing to a
generative model as formly specified um
in terms of variational inference but we
can relax that and just say some kind of
model of the world that entails a
certain aspect of selfhood to it um so
that's what I would I would say I I put
something else into the mixed mix as
well that to be conscious I suspect in
the way that you're talking about um
means you have to be an agent and to be
an agent means that you have to be able
to act and I would say more than just
acting more than acting um say for
example in the way that plants will act
to broadcast information that enables
them to mount an immune response to
parasites they have the capacity to plan
uh and which is it brings us back to the
Curiosity again because you know we
normally plan in order to resolve
uncertainty we normally plan our day and
the way that we um um spend our time
gathering information gathering evidence
for our models of the world in a way
that can only be described as looks as
if it is curious that's why I was so
fixated on Art and creativity and
curiosity that josa was was talking
about P say I I think that is um
probably a prerequisite for being
conscious in the sense that josa would
would mean it but I don't know perhaps
we should ask ask ask him that may I ask
you a clarifying question Carl about
belief updating so if Consciousness is
associated with belief updating then
let's say one is a computer a classical
computer you get updated in discreet
steps whereas the belief updating that I
imagine you're referring to is something
more fuzzy or continuous so does that
mean that the Consciousness associated
with a computer if a computer could be
conscious is of a different sort how
does that work I'm not sure I don't I
don't think there's any uh In The Same
Spirit that we don't want to um
overcommit to neurons doing you know
doing mind work um um I don't think we
need to commit to a continuous or
discreet uh space space-time formulation
you know again it's that that that's
artificial divide between classical
physics and quantum uh Quantum
information theoretic approaches um so
you know I think the deeper question is
what what um what properties must the
computational process in a uh PC or a
computer possess before you could uh you
would be licensed to make the influence
that it was conscious and possibly even
ascribe self-consciousness to to that
and the way that I would articulate that
would be that you have to be able to
describe everything that is observed
able about that Computing
artifact uh as if or explain it in terms
of it acting upon the world in a way
that suggests or can be explained that
it has a model of itself engaging with
that World um and furthermore I would
say that um that that that model um has
to
involve the consequences of its action
that which is what I meant by being an
agent so it has to have a model that um
or act as if it has a Model A generative
model that could be you know a minimal
self kind of model but crucially entails
the consequences of its own actions so
that it can plan so that can it can
evince curious like like Behavior so
that could be done in silica it could be
done with a sort of clock and you know
um uh um and
synchronous or synchronous message
passing of a discrete sort it could be
done in analog it could be done with
photonics it could be done under
neuromorphic architecture I don't think
that really matters I I think it's more
the nature of the implicit model under
the hood that is accounting for its
internal machinations but more um
practically in terms of what I can
observe of that computer Its Behavior in
the way that it goes and gathers
information um or attend to certain
things and not attend doesn't uh attend
to other things okay great
yosa if we think about where
Consciousness is we might be biased in
by our um propensity to assign identity
to everything and identity does not
apply to lawlike things gravity is not
somewhere gravity is a law for instance
or combustion is not anywhere it's a law
it doesn't mean that it happens
everywhere in the same same way it only
happens when the conditions for the
manifestation of the law are um
implemented when they're realized in a
certain region then we can observe
combustion happening but combustion
simply means that under certain
conditions you will get an exothermic
reaction and uh gravity means that under
certain conditions you will find that uh
objects attract each other and
Consciousness means that if you uh set
up a system in a certain way you will
observe the following
phenomena uh Consciousness in this way
is Software State it's representation
State and all software is not a thing
but the word processor that runs on your
computer doesn't have an identity that
would make it separate or uh uh the same
as the word processor that runs on
another person's computer because it's a
law it says if you put the transistors
into this and this state the following
thing is going to happen so a software
engineer is discovering a law a very
very specific law that is tailored to a
particular task and so on but it's
manifested whenever we create the
preconditions for that law and so the
software design is about creating the
preconditions for the manifestation of a
law of uh text processing for instance
that allows you to implement such a
function in the universe or discover how
it is implemented but it's not because
the uh software engineer builds it into
existence and it didn't exist before
that that's not the case right it always
would work if you somebody discovers
this bite this bit string in a random
way and it's the same bit string
implemented on the same architecture it
would still will perform the same
function and in this sense um I think
that Consciousness is not separate in
different people it's itself a mechanism
a principle that uh increases coherence
in the mind it's an operator that seems
to be increasing coherence at least
that's the way I would look at it or
frame it and uh as a result it produces
a sense of now an island of coherence in
uh the potential models that our mind
could have and it I think it's
responsible for this fact that we
perceive our ourselves being inhabitants
of an island of coherence in a caotic
world this now this island of nness and
it's probably not the only solution for
this thing I think it's imaginable that
there could be a hyperconsciousness that
allows you to see multiple possibilities
simultaneously rather than just one as
our Consciousness does or that offers us
a now that is not three seconds long but
hundreds of years
long in principle that I think is
conceivable so maybe uh we will have
systems at some point may we already
have them that have different
Consciousness like structures that
fulfill a similar role of C islands of
coherence or um inter interal regions of
in the space of representations that
allow you to act on the
universe but uh the way it's seems to be
implemented in myself it's PR clearly in
the brain because if I disrupt my brain
my Consciousness ceases whereas if I
disrupt my body it doesn't this doesn't
mean that there are not feedback loops
that are B directional into my body body
or even outside of my body that are
crucial for some fun functionality that
I observe as a content in my
Consciousness but uh if you want to make
me unconscious you need to clobber my
brain in some sense not nothing else
there's no other part of the universe
that you can inhibit to make me
unconscious and that leads me to think
that the way in which this law-like
structure is implemented is right now
for the system that is talking to you on
my neurons on my brain
mostly okay any objections there Carl no
not at all I I I was just trying to
remember if Mark Soulard here were here
um he tell you exactly um the size of a
really small region in the brain stem I
think it's less than 4 cubic millimeters
that if you were blad you would
immediately lose Consciousness like that
so you don't you it's a very it's a very
very specific part of your neuronal
architecture um that um permits
conscious a conscious process but there
are also very specific Parts in my
computer that are extremely small that I
could obliterate and ablate and I would
instantly uh lead to the sensation of
all the interesting functions of my
computer and there are many of such
regions where there basic crucial
bottlenecks that enable a large scale
functionality and some sense everything
that would disrupt the formation of
coherent patterns in my brain is
sufficient to inhibit my Consciousness
and there are probably many uh such
bottlenecks that provide the
vulnerability so maybe the claustrum is
uh cral in providing some clock function
that is uh crucial for uh the formation
of feedback loops in the brain that give
rise to the kind of patterns that we
need maybe there are several other such
bottlenecks this doesn't mean that the
functionality is exclusively implemented
in this bottleneck no I didn't mean to
imply that the pineal gland I think that
you would but I thought it could lead to
a misunderstanding of the audience and I
I've heard famous neuroscientists point
at such phenomena and say oh maybe this
is where consciousness happens I think
this is almost a superstitious belief
it's like saying oh there's this
particular chip on my computer if I
destroy it the computer doesn't work
anymore uh and maybe this was just a
quartz uh or something else rather than
the stuff that is providing the
interesting functionality or or the lead
to the battery perhaps um so so which
neuroscientists has said this then I'm
not naming
names you email me afterwards
right just to unpack um the reason that
Mark would identify this is it is
exactly the cells of origin that are
broadcast everywhere that do uh induce
exactly this coherence you were talking
about these are the ascending modulatory
neurotransmitter systems that are
responsible for orchestrating that
coherence that you were that you were
talking about and I think that's very
nice because um you know it also speaks
to
um the ability of sort
of conscious mimicking like
artifacts um that are that uh whose
abilities to mimic Consciousness like
Behavior rests upon this modulatory
attention like mechanism and I'm
thinking again of attention heads and
Transformers that play the same kind of
role as the um the selection that these
ascending neurotransmitter systems do so
if you found yourself in conversation
with Mark SS he would argue that the the
feeling of consciousness
arises from equipping certain coherent
coordinated interactions that may be
regulated by the Cel or the claustrum
but it is that regulation that that
actually equips Consciousness with with
the kind of qualitative feeling that at
least in the way that Mark SS uh Mark SS
addresses but I mean just notice that um
just reviewing what Josh just said there
he's talking about um Consciousness your
equipping as with a sense of now and
having an explicit um aspect that could
be um you know I'm thinking of um not
hle but well actually Jerry adelman's
notion of the remembered present you
know which could be the cognitive moment
300 milliseconds or it could be if I was
a tree three years uh I think it's a
lovely notion but the the point being
we're talking about processes in
time you we're not saying at this
instant I am conscious or Consciousness
is here we're talking about a a process
that that by definition has to unfold um
unfold in time so you know I think
that's an important observation which
sometimes
eludes I think people debating about
State conscious States and conscious
content um you know not acknowledging
that it is a process it is a process
what was the example that Josh Joshua
mentioned combustion yeah combustion is
a process you know you you can't be in a
state of combustion uh and you you could
even argue that it's very difficult to
localize um at a c a certain level but
the key thing is it's a process I hav't
open question and maybe you have a
reflection on this when we think about
our own Consciousness we cannot know in
principle I think um just by
introspection whether we have multiple
Consciousness in our own mind because we
can only remember those conscious states
that find their way into an integrated
protocol that you can access from where
you stand and we know that there are
some people which have a multiple
personality disorder in which the
protocol itself gets
splintered as a result they don't dream
to be just one person they dream to be
alternating to be different people that
usually don't remember each other
because they don't have that shared
protocol anymore now uh my own emotion
and perception is generated outside of
my personal self my personal self is
Downstream from them I am subjected to
my perception and emotion I have
involuntary reactions to them but to
produce my percepts and my um emotion my
mind needs
intelligence right it cannot be much
more stupid than me if my emotions would
guide me in a way that is consistently
more stupid than my reason and my
reflection would be uh I don't think I
would work so there is an interesting
question is there secondary
Consciousness is the part of your mind
that generates World model and your
assessment your alignment to the world
it's self-conscious so basic do you
share uh your brain with the second
Consciousness that has a separate
protocol or is this a non-conscious
process that is basically just dump and
doesn't know what it's doing um in a
sense that it's would be sentient in a
way that's similar to my own sentience
what do you
think C you should have a go on that one
and then I'll I can think about
it well something I had wondered about
10 years ago or so and I don't recall
the exact argument was that if it was
the case that the graph in our brain
let's say that let's just reduce the
neurons down to a graph that this graph
somehow produces Consciousness or is the
same as Consciousness then if you were
to remove one of those nodes then you
would still have a somewhat the same
identity okay so then does that mean
that we have pretty much an infinite
amount of overlapping consciousnesses
within our brain I don't recall the
exact argument but it was similar to
this and then there's something related
in philosophy called a binding problem
I'm uncertain what people who study
multiple personality disorders have to
say about The Binding problem like is
that The Binding problem gone
arai can I just then pursue that notion
of the
um binding in the context of the kind of
thing that uh or the way I am at the
moment yeah I think that's a very
compelling notion um uh from the point
of view of generative modeling so I'm
not as answering now as as a philosopher
but as somebody who may be tasked for
example with building um an artifact
that would have a minimal kind of
selfhood the first thing you have to
write down is um different states of
mind um so that I can be frightened I
can be embarrassed I can be um uh Angry
I can uh be a father I could be a
football player I could be so all the
different ways that I could be that are
now conditioned upon the context in
which I uh find myself and if that's
part of the generative model that then
speaks to two things that first of all
you have to recognize what state of mind
you are in and given all the evidence at
hand so for example um if I want to
jointly
explain the racing heart that I um my
interceptive cues are um providing me in
the intercepted domain with um a
stiffness of my muscles that my prop
perception is equipping me with um then
to reconcile that with my uh visual
exceptive input that I'm in a dark alley
um and pneumonic I've never been here
before all of the sensory evidence might
be quite easily explained by the simple
hypothesis I am frightened
and that in turn uh
generates um covert or mental actions
and possibly even overt autonomic
actions and motor actions that uh
provide more evidence for the fact that
I am frightened in the sense in a
William James sense that you know I have
cardia acceleration I will have a motor
response a muscular response appropriate
for a fright and or flight uh flight
response so just to actually be able to
generate and
recognize emotional kinds of behavior I
would need to have a minimal kind of
model that crucially um um obliged me
now to disambiguate between a a series
of different ways of being if you
enjoyed that clip then the full podcast
is out right now you can click around
here enjoy subscribe to theories of
everything to get notified of upcoming
podcasts as there new full length
podcasts every week on the topics of
mathematics physics Consciousness Free
Will and
AI